this man is uh always a great chat
whenever he comes on the show and
there's lots going on in the world
i would love to pick his brain on his
thoughts i follow him on twitter
and you can also check out the right
time with bomani jones podcast he is
bomani jones how are you sir
i'm good man how about you i am doing
better uh
what story interests you more than
anything else right now that
appears to be at the top of a a headline
stack is it what's going on in the nfl
nba rogers tebow tonight's lakers
next i'll give you the uh omnibus choice
what what interests you
what's the topic i understand that we've
been beating this thing into the ground
but there's nothing more interesting
than what's going on with aaron rodgers
right now right
this is no way around it where i think i
am one of the few people
who is willing to come out in public and
say i
understand why they drafted
jordan love like i don't even think that
that was necessarily a terrible decision
it was only a terrible decision if you
did not realize that as soon as you
drafted him that meant that he would be
the starter in 2021
didn't matter what aaron rodgers did in
2020 you were going to have to make that
move
if you decided to take a quarterback and
they apparently did not
understand that this is what it was it
is like we know somehow we've never met
aaron rodgers but we know him better
than they do
and they seem to be really surprised
that this is going right now when it was
so eminently
predictable and now i have no idea what
the world they're going to do and
i still don't know what your love looks
like no idea
you can walk down the street and not be
able to to say oh that's your love right
you have no idea let me tell you a whole
lot of people go walk
across jordan love and a similar
circumstance to be like really you uh
went to utah state like like i just i
just think that
in all of it and by the way they don't
seem to know anything about him either
because he came
in in the worst offseason ever to be a
rookie and you know there's no camp
he didn't dress for any of the games
last year they literally have
no idea whether their first round pick
from last year
can do anything as of this moment right
now and that's an absurd thing to say as
a pro franchise
it is because if you think about it
bomani at some point because we're
we're focusing on the possib enough
focusing but we're talking about
uh my colleague at nfl media group bucky
brooks certainly threw it out there as a
possibility for the ravens being the
first to do it because at the time
you know lamar jackson didn't have his
fifth year option picked up that at some
point
somebody is going to go in the direction
of drafting somebody in the first round
and instead of giving them a fifth year
option contract
and picking that up and then trying to
figure out what the next iteration of a
contract looks like
they'll just be like college they'll
just let that player graduate and
they'll start the clock again with a new
rookie quarterback and try and win that
way again
and instead we're seeing the packers say
okay instead of
choosing someone in the first round and
then throwing all of our resources in to
make sure we win
in that first iteration of a contract
before we get cap hamstrung with him
we'll just let him sit
it just makes no sense none of it makes
sense on that front
at all yeah like i i thought that if
somebody
were going to do kind of that graduation
thing that it would be jared goff
and then the rams gave him a boatload of
cash like right after i was like you
know this guy probably isn't really that
good you could probably get another one
of those they were like oh no we got to
give him the money right now and then
two years later we're like anybody want
a quarterback
we've got a quarterback that you guys
can have if you would like to have one
and then they ship them out um but with
with what they're doing
with rogers one this is probably a rude
awakening a lot for a lot of those young
guys on the team where they look up and
they realize that they'll do it to aaron
rodgers they'll do it to you like
everybody thinks they different until
they realize they're not and this is the
clearest demonstration that you probably
will not
wind up uh being different in the grand
scheme of it
but i also think the packers learn
something that it's hard to build
for tomorrow and today at the same time
like this is the question i had about
san francisco when they made the trade
to get a quarterback this year
that's a win later move and you tell me
that you have a win now team
and so the packers had a win now team
and they made a win later move and now
good luck with later yeah because the
the later in the now are absolutely
on different tracks of team building
certainly when you've got
a quarterback like rogers who you can't
even say was showing diminishing returns
i mean they made an
nfc championship game and won 13 games
in the new coach who
supposedly was going to be so young and
so difficult for him to
if you will rogers changes spots in a
way to to
attach himself at the hip of this guy
and he did exactly that and then you
drafted
the quarterback by moving up to take him
again the fact that we're still talking
about this a year later because the
that's the now is kind of stunning to me
it really really is
it's tough to handle i thought when they
drafted him
if like if for some reason they had been
in the top 10
they would have really i thought had a
bit of a trick bag of decision because
rogers i did think
in 18 and 19 did not look like the
quarterback that we had seen before and
so much of his game is predicated on
athleticism
so if you thought that he was declining
as an athlete then maybe you start
looking at the future but
every single quarterback who has been
taken in the first round
since the rookie weight scale came about
the only exception is paxton lynch
they all were the starters by year two
like the schedule had been laid out on
this and these were the only people that
thought now we'll just
keep going until aaron can't play
anymore like aaron was just gonna be
like i'm just gonna keep going till they
tell me i'm sorry yeah because that's
the aaron rodgers that we've seen
he's definitely giving you the vibe
that's how he gets down oh he has
it bomani jones here on the rich eisen
show host of the right time with bomani
jones podcast let's
talk about tebow what is your two cents
on the subject of t
tebow getting a a shot to make the
jacksonville jaguars from his old
college coach
i just thought it was really stupid of
mire
to make this play i mean first of all to
do 33 years old right like i don't i
don't see any way
that he makes it onto the roster or
anything i
i am stunned that a man who is tim
tebow's age and has stepped away from
getting the hell knocked out of him for
as long as he has
now suddenly wants to have it happen
again like that that that
part on his end i don't get but urban
meyer this idea that tim tebow
if the idea is that he's going to help
impart the culture and he's going to be
some like locker room type guy
they only listen to you if you're good
like you're not going to come in here
out of nowhere having not been in the
league not having any people in there
and they're going to be the one that
showed these guys
how it's done like that's not going to
happen parcells used to do this a lot
we would bring guys like pepper johnson
and maurice carthage
and you know they would be the guys to
impart the parcels wait
but they were still like when he would
do that they were still like nfl players
they still halfway decent guys
he bo ain't even know nfl player which
means he's gonna look like the snitch
like why are you here oh cause i'm
friends with the coach he's like a dad
to me
okay i'm not gonna do anything around
you
yeah i remember when parcells was with
the jets at the end of uh
you know his run before the cowboys he
brought in keith byers dave megat
and they were players they were players
they were important players
on that team i think pepper might even
be right this dude couldn't play when he
was playing
what do you make however of the sense
that people are saying that this
is the latest affront to kaepernick that
that tebow's getting a shot
and kaepernick uh did not get one uh
obviously with the exception of that one
thrown together tryout by the nfl two
years ago that i'm still wondering what
the hell happened
to make it happen and then when it
happened what what's your two cents on
that subject
yeah i think that this one is a separate
discussion for what happened with
kaepernick like we
it doing that in this case means that we
could do it with literally
every signing that we have and so like
when blake bortles or blaine kaffir
winds up getting another job yeah okay
we can go ahead and talk about this
this is about urban meyer bringing on
his buddy
i don't think that this is really tied
to anything like hugely macro
beyond that it's urban meyer bringing in
his buddy and again i
don't think that he's going to get
anywhere near the actual
roster like i think it's going to be a
moot point by the time the season starts
i'm just blown away
that he would even do this in the first
place and
from the sounds of it people in the
organization were not
on board with this and he still did it
anyway like i think this is going to be
a learning experience for him that
like this just isn't college in the way
that you want it to be
so you don't think you know the fact
that they could
get tebow the reps and otas and stuff
and he's gonna prob he's probably right
now while we're talking
probably in front of some jugs machine
catching his 19 000 football of the day
and you know you know he's gonna be he's
gonna he's gonna do his best to make
this happen you don't think that this
could wind up being one of those
my gosh if he had only done this ten
years ago type
stories bomani jones you don't feel that
no because i don't
i don't think he was that athletic in
the first place like i thought he was
athletic for a college quarterback like
he definitely demonstrated that level of
athleticism there
but i don't think that he demonstrated
an nfl level of athleticism like he's
not
fast he could move but i think he's like
a 4-8 guy
or something like that and he does not
have a great deal of practice at
anything called
blocking or anything like that and so
maybe
at 23 there was a possibility that we
could have looked at it this way
him jumping in the league at 33 and
being a tight end like
i understand that kyle pitts is an
exceptional case in terms of athleticism
but that's what tight ends look like
these days
those are the things that tight ends can
do now i've seen nothing for tim tebow
to indicate that he could do those
things
bomani jones here on the rich eisen show
the right time with bomani jones podcast
get it where all podcasts
can be acquired big game tonight i think
between the lakers and the knicks it's
not as if the lakers don't have a
spotlight on them
all the time but now the national
spotlight with turner coming in and the
knicks having the same record
and this is a terrific barometer test
again for the knicks they seem to be
having one every single
night um lebron may or may not be back
for this you know lebron said i'm not
going to be 100
anymore he's fearful so on and so forth
with the playing tournament that lebron
has criticized staring the lakers
directly in the face
with a meeting with steph curry it
appears and how hot he is
what do you make of the lakers current
situation and future over the next
couple of
months should it happen bomani jones
well i don't think they're going to win
a championship
and i think lebron was probably being a
wee bit dramatic when he said the thing
about not being 100
ever again in his career but he's also
in his 18th year in the nba and his game
is still
in large part or running in jumping
games so with a high ankle sprain
which like is one of those things but
kind of like turf tube where we talk
about it all the time but nobody
understands exactly what it is
and the high ankle spray is like you
know how people roll their ankles
normally
is if you roll it the other way like you
brought how much force you have to put
down
on your ankle to even have a high ankle
sprain because your leg is built to stop
something like that
from happening i don't think he's gonna
wind up being at a hundred percent this
year i do think that they're gonna wind
up being
in the play-in tournament i think
they'll get out of that play in
tournament
but i think that they are
unless something pretty drastic changes
pretty quickly i just have a hard time
seeing them going deep
into the playoffs this year that said
uh if i am adam silver i'm sending in
earl hebner
or whoever else i need to to make sure
the lakers do make it into the playoffs
like this playing tournament is looking
like a boon form right now because
there's going to be interesting teams in
it but if it results in the lakers not
making the playoffs it's the worst thing
they ever did
i think we're learning over the last
couple of weeks and months
you know what what this looks like
without lebron the lakers look like
without lebron
and what the league looks like without
lebron you know i guess
be careful what you wish for if you want
lebron finally gone
you know yeah so like on one hand i do
think that the league is
like the they're suffering from some of
the effects of leaning so heavily into
lebron because there's not that much
left that's interesting about lebron
after all these years right like he's
not going to catch jordan
in the eyes of people you can't call him
a choker any of that stuff anymore now
he's one of
very many excellent players who are in
the nba he's still right near the top
but that's still like not really
compelling
i don't think anymore to people at this
point however
those are still the lakers and so people
who don't care that much about
basketball with you the lakers are on
television
and still watch like if they mess around
and get one of those finals
where they've got something like utah
and milwaukee
which might be highly entertaining and
like 15 of us are going to know about it
and we're going to talk about man one of
the greatest series ever sure if people
watched it
who's your mvp oh yo it's not even close
like i can't believe that people have
tried to make this into something
compelling which i think is just largely
because they don't think that dude
looks like somebody who should be like
really excellent at basketball but he's
one of the most amazing players to watch
that i can think of and when you go look
at the advanced numbers this is like
borderline top 10 all-time season that
he is putting up like it's him
and if indeed it stay healthy maybe
would be we'd be talking about him in
this discussion
but it is jokic and i don't even care
who number two is so you're saying
he he looks like big country plays like
magic is that what you're basically
saying
bomani dude it's so wild because he does
like
you know i'm surprised that he's been in
the league this long and hadn't gotten a
better haircut
like one of my favorite things about the
nba is all these guys who come from
europe and their indoctrination to
american culture is
actually nba culture so you know you get
some guys i don't know where you know
what i'm saying you know you're like oh
wait wait when did that happen oh that
you learned how to speak english in the
nba and normally somebody would have
taken them to the right barbershop by
now and he'd had some lines in his head
or something else like that george
mearson was walking around here dressed
like daylight soul when he was in the
league and yogurt is still out here with
that haircut i don't get it
de la soul it's maybe the best reference
we've had on this show in quite some
time
but you know i maybe the fact that jokic
is not being
widely you know overarchingly in your is
your point i guess
by what you made considered the mvp
as a lock is because you know the
nuggets and
he were an afterthought until you know
jamal murray went down then it's like oh
okay the fact that you're actually
taking a step
forward instead of being totally done
for the year fork stuck
that might be it but um and and then you
look at
obviously embiid for the sixers i know
he went down for a bit but the sixers
may wind up with the best record in the
east
if not writ large so maybe that's what
it is
about the joker you know and there's the
mountain time zone
like things that happen specifically in
the mountain time zone we
we we keep up with the teams on the
pacific we for whatever reason the
mountain time zone could be a place
where you can quickly go to disappear
because it's strange to me they went to
the western conference finals last year
like it wasn't simply that the clippers
blew that series the nuggets also came
and they took it from them and so i
expected people to be a bit more
interested i think the playoffs will be
a good barometer for people to see what
they have because what has happened
since murray has come out has gone out
it's something i think is really
interesting as an nba story that is
being under discuss which is the
emergence of future superstar michael
porter jr
um and when when murray went out my
question was going to be
are they going to be about the same
without him simply because this means
that porter is gonna have to do more and
he has had to do more and he has done
more
and he got a 610 dude that's shooting
like 55 from the floor
like 45 from three like the nuggets are
coming
like people need to start getting ready
because i think they're going to be good
for a long time
bomani always appreciate the chat thanks
for uh
for being able to make it today and uh i
look forward to the next time already
thanks again
no no probably bad you guys be good you
got it the right time with bomani jones
podcast get it where all podcasts can be
acquired that's bomani jones
here on the rich eisen show de la souls
a fun like george mirasan looked like de
la soul
funny funny funny
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here